in the past two years the money supply
has increased from 15.5 trillion dollars
to 21.8 trillion dollars
this has caused asset valuations to go
parabolic and inflation to go through
the roof
we're seeing cpi readings come in at
over eight percent and gas prices in
some parts of the country have scored
past six dollars per gallon despite all
these red flags for the longest time the
federal reserve was insisting that
inflation was simply transitory and that
it was just a matter of time until
prices stabilized while the market was
somewhat skeptical of this idea it gave
the fed some credit until the fed rock
pulled everyone and became extremely
hawkish ever since then the stock market
has gotten crushed with many mega tech
companies falling 50 60 70 from their
all-time highs meanwhile the housing
market is starting to show its first
signs of weakness with the new home
sales dropping off substantially
considering all this you would expect
for the dollar to currently be
performing at a clifton maneuver and
this is what's happening from a nominal
perspective however from a relative
perspective the dollar is actually
skyrocketing wait wait wait wait wait
what am i even talking about well i'm
talking about the dollar index or ticker
symbol dxy
if you're not familiar with the dollar
index it seeks to measure the strength
of the us dollar relative to a basket of
foreign currencies and over the past 12
months the dxy has moved to multi-year
highs and if you really want to get
technical with it you'll see that the
dxy has actually reached a slightly
higher level than the peaks of the past
several years
in fact the last time the dxy was higher
than this was way back in december of
2002 or nearly 20 years ago and if you
don't believe me just take a look at
foreign conversion rates the euro for
example has fallen to multi-year lows
against a dollar and it's nearly at one
dollar per euro
similarly the british pound is also
testing multi-year lows against a dollar
and the last time the pound was sizably
weaker than this was way back in 1985.
so clearly while the us dollar is
getting crushed in terms of buying power
it's actually gaining dominance on the
world currencies so what in the world is
going on with a dollar
starting with the biggest culprit we
have supply and demand though we often
like to think of currencies as a stable
medium of exchange during regular times
currencies are actually subject to all
of the same supply and demand
characteristics that affect something
like the stock market currencies simply
have extremely low volatility during
regular times however with the
groundbreaking events like printing
trillions of dollars followed up by
suddenly raising interest rates it's not
surprising that even currencies are
experiencing abnormally high volatility
also something to note is that it's not
just the us who has been engaging in
such activities either most of the world
central banks have engaged in very
similar monetary policies take the
european central bank or the ecb for
example since the pandemic started it
they have also pumped trillions of euros
into the market now this isn't quite as
high as the us in terms of dollars but
the thing to note is that relative to
economic metrics the money printing of
other central banks are just as high if
not higher for example the total gdp of
all the european union countries that
use the euro is 12.23 trillion dollars
while this is an extremely respectable
figure it's only about 60 of the united
states 20.94 trillion gdp now this isn't
an exact science by any means but this
leads us to believe that the ecba cannot
print more than 60 of the dollars
printed by the us if they want to
maintain the exchange rate between the
two currencies this same principle
applies to smaller economies as well the
uk for example has a gdp of 2.7 trillion
dollars which is a little more than an
eighth of the us given that the us has
increased their money supply by about
6.3 trillion dollars this means that the
uk could increase their money supply by
about 800 billion dollars however the uk
has surpassed this threshold by quite a
bit so far the uk has printed 895
billion pounds if we use the average
pound to dollar conversion rate in 2021
of a
1.3757 we'll see that this money
printing correlates to 1.231 trillion
dollars which is over 50 higher than
what they should have theoretically
printed if you look into the money
printing of some other leading nations
you'll see that they have fallen into
the same trap of printing more money
than the us on a relative basis on top
of this many of these countries aren't
pulling back nearly as aggressively as
the us currently is and for obvious
reasons this has led to the us dollar
performing quite well in relation to
these foreign currencies
[Music]
aside from fundamental supply and demand
factors external fears have also
influenced the dollar's recent parabolic
move one of the top concerns for most
investors right now is how hawkish the
fed will be over the next couple of
months currently there are rumors
floating around that the fed will hike
rates by 75 basis points not once but
twice both in june and july whether this
ends up happening or not the stock
market has already preemptively
corrected for this some would even argue
that it has over corrected for this
regardless of whether the market
sell-off is justified or not though in
the end significant amounts of capital
have left the market by now i'm sure
most of you guys have seen my videos on
how several companies have been shedding
hundreds of billions of dollars in
market cap and while a lot of this value
just evaporates away the primary place
the remaining capital is going is cash
which is significantly driving up the
demand for us dollars something else to
note is that it's only the stock market
that has acted preemptively the real
estate market is yet to react if the
rumors regarding the fed end up coming
true the fed would have raised interest
rates by two percent within a matter of
six months theoretically home prices
should drop ten percent for every one
percent interest rates go up and the
given that home prices have just started
to level off this could mean that they
have a rough six to 12 months ahead and
once again where does all the cash
leaving the real estate market go it
goes to cash which further increases
demand for the dollar in the short term
also it's not just people pulling back
on their investments either some of the
largest companies in the world will
substantially pull back as well now of
course elon is out there trying to buy
twitter but he's an anomaly instead take
a look at someone like amazon amazon
just posted their first quarterly loss
in seven years due to losses from
rivienne increasing supply chain costs
and slowing revenue growth do you really
think amazon is going to go out and make
big acquisitions anytime soon probably
not the more likely scenario is that
they're going to hold cash and prepare
for a market downturn similarly apple is
warning investors that sales could drop
by as much as 8 billion dollars within
the coming months pair this with rumors
that the iphone 14 will be even more
underwhelming than usual and i don't
think it's very likely that apple will
be making any big moves anytime soon and
that's just apple and amazon i don't
even think i need to discuss the states
of paypal netflix and facebook now none
of this is to say that a market crash is
even around the corner in the first
place after all crashes don't happen
when everyone is expecting it but the
key is that everyone from retail
investors and small businesses the hedge
funds and mega cab companies are
expecting it and consequently preparing
for it and all this uncertainty is
giving the us dollars significant buying
pressure
during times of high inflation one of
the first things investors do it is move
a significant portion of their wealth
into inflation hedges historically the
most popular inflation hedge has been
gold for example in the 1970s when the
u.s was experiencing double-digit
inflation rates the price of gold went
vertical between 1976 and 1980 the price
of gold went from 100 per ounce to 875
per ounce
today inflation is once again almost in
double-digit territory however people
haven't really been flocking towards
gold
in fact gold hasn't really moved since
july of 2020. not to mention and it's
not like these are new levels for gold
either in fact gold reached these same
levels way back in 2011. if we take a
look at silver the story is even bleaker
between 1976 and 1980 silver grew over
10x from 3.80 cents per ounce to 48.34
cents per ounce today however like gold
silver hasn't moved since july of 2020.
what makes silver even worse though is
that it's literally 50 lower today than
it was at the peak of 1980. of course
many silver bulls would argue that this
is precisely why silver is such a good
investment and that it's extremely
undervalued right now they could be
absolutely right and silver may be on
the cusp of a historic rally but as of
right now silver nor gold has really
done much meaning that very little cash
has flowed into these inflation edges
it's not just historic inflation hedges
that aren't getting any love either the
best example of this is bitcoin many
bitcoin bulls suggest that bitcoin is
the new gold and that it's the perfect
inflation hazard given that its supply
is capped at 21 million coins ethereum
bulls would argue that ether is an even
greater inflation hedge than bitcoin
given that ether is actually headed
towards becoming a deflationary
cryptocurrency yet despite all this
neither bitcoin or ethereum are rallying
substantially in fact they're both down
nearly 50 percent now i gotta say even
though bitcoin and ethereum are by no
means making new all-time highs they've
actually been holding up extremely well
given that they're down less than
companies like netflix and paypal with
that being said though we have yet to
see any meaningful move towards
inflation hedges meaning that all the
money people are cashing out of the
stock market and the bond market is just
in cash and this is keeping demand for
the dollar quite high
at the end of the day the main takeaway
from all of this is that despite all the
fed's quantitative easing the dollar is
actually still holding up extremely
strong from a global perspective now
this does not help by any means for
inflation or prices after all if the u.s
has a 10 inflation rate while the rest
of the world has a 15 inflation rate the
dollar would still be performing
extremely well in relation the main
factor is driving forward the dollar
right now it is an enormous amount of
money printing from other countries
extreme uncertainty in the market
regarding the fed and the very low
inflation hedging taking place
looking forward whether this momentum
will continue or not comes down to the
threat stands over the next couple of
months and whether inflation starts to
cool down substantially if inflation
cools down and the fed backs off then
it's very possible that we enter a risk
on market once again and during a risk
on market people don't hold cash rather
they invest it all into assets which
drives down the demand for the dollar
this could cause the dxy to stagnate or
even start running down on the other
hand if inflation continues to get worse
and the fed becomes even more hawkish
the market might become even more risk
off causing the dollar to reach levels
that it hasn't seen in decades but we'll
just have to wait and see do you guys
think the dxy is going up or down
comment that down below
also drop a like if you're hoping that
inflation cools off sooner rather than
later and of course consider checking
out our international channels to watch
your videos in other languages and
consider subscribing to see more
questions logically answered but until
then i'm hari and i'll see you guys on
the next one
you